migrant workers in Qatar many of whom
have been building the country's stadia
for the 2022 World Cup require approval
from their boss before they can change
jobs or even leave the country that is
set to change next year the Gulf state
has agreed to abolish Kafala labor and
introduce a minimum wage law that would
not discriminate against nationalities
it is very important because we are
looking at you know Qatar to be an
attractive place for investors for the
skilled workers to have productive or
community Amnesty International has long
called for an end to the abusive system
in Qatar it praised the announcement as
a major step forward but the
organization also remains cautious the
devil will be in the detail far too
often workers have continued to face
exploitation and abuse despite reforms
the pressure to reform has been a
sticking point
ever since the working conditions of
Qatar's migrant workers were exposed
especially under the spotlight of world
cup preparations one agency that has
been working closely with Qatar on
reforming its system is the United
Nations International Labour
Organization well you know for us it's
it's been long overdue it still exists
in many other countries and we're hoping
that other countries will also follow
suit and fully abolish to follow Qatar
is in need of an image boost before they
host the 2022 World Cup it's unclear how
far these labor reforms will actually go
what is certain actions will speak
louder than words I want to dive deeper
on that story now we're joined by who
ton home a young boy who actually saw
him there in the piece he's a
representative of the International
Labour Organization that's the UN agency
that's been working closely with Qatar
on these reforms now first of all thank
you for joining us from Doha we've seen
reports of course about these working
conditions for years now from migrants
in Qatar you've been there on the ground
how would you describe the situation
thanks for having me on we've been here
for about a year and a half working very
closely with the government and thus far
as you've heard major milestones have
been achieved the job is not done yet
but the full abolishment of Kavala
is a huge milestone for all of us for
the country for the international trade
unions for the employer organizations
the establishment of the
non-discriminatory minimum wage is also
a huge milestone for the region not just
let me just Hansen here wonders to
clarify sorry to interrupt but you
mentioned Kafala the abolishment of that
now they just explain for us what is
Kafala so Kafala is the sponsorship
system basically if a migrant worker
wants to come to work in the state of
Qatar then they would have to have a
sponsor and when they come into the
country if they want to leave
temporarily or permanently they would
have to get the approval of their
employer also if they wanted to change
their employment they would have to give
you a pool of their employer and that
all comes to an end January 2020 so they
no longer will we no longer will have
this power imbalance between employers
and workers you also mentioned there a
minimum wage I mean do we have any idea
how big that minimum wage will be and
and who that will appointed so the
actual amount has not been announced yet
we know that the Council of Ministers
has endorsed the establishment into law
non-discriminatory minimum wage for all
nationalities across all sectors we
jointly in collaboration with the
Ministry of Labour carried out a study
over an eight month period and we have
made certain proposals on whether the
amount should be we proposed a range and
it's up to the National constituents to
decide where they would actually fix the
exact amount Qatar has promised these
sorts of reforms in the past right I
mean how confident are you that these
measures will now work to improve these
workers rights
as your piece just before our interview
said actions speak louder than words and
I fully agree with that you know with
this major milestones as soon as they
come into effect January 2020 it will
benefit millions of migrant workers here
if they no longer need to obtain the
approval of their employer to leave the
country that's a direct immediate impact
on these workers on their lives when
there is a minimum wage that offers a
minimum standard of decent living and
working for migrant workers that has an
immediate impact on their lives and
their families lives so these are really
legislations that are very important and
they will directly impact the lives of
migrant workers who turn home a young
poor the head of the International
Labour Organization projects office in
Qatar thank you so much for giving us
your perspective Thanks